quand il est descendu pour acheter des
cigarettes
jean-pierre savait déjà il ne reviendra
la pensée embarras toute sa vie avec
michel
et puis la tour et ans
le point de larmes
richard
toi
entrée
mais lui ne se voyait pas
ce jour en marketing advenant son café
les cours de la livre s'affairer
et des enfants
ensemble
non plus
voilà
cela
il s'en allait
où
voilà pour
cela
sans aller
elle
il savait qu 1,8 à la table serait mis à
côté de son assiette il reste qu'en
utilisant s'il fallait ces saloperies
pour arriver à s'endormir
ce n'était pas la planète
et puis la vie
ce qu'il allait devenir
mais il n'en pouvait plus de vie
le plus de sa vie n'était pas d'avoir un
jour un con ensuite
ce n'était pas
une enquête
cela
ils sont à l'heure
voilà vous
cela
s'en alla
j'ai remis hier
ou ses amis l'attendent
il ya deux hommes
la crise entraîne de rien
la station sens
mais demain deux hommes
et moi
aussi michel amoureux celle qui lui tél
on voit son travail
c'est de la vraie complicité la vie déjà
mais sérieuse le supérieur
ils se retrouvent pas
cela
s'en alla
ils sont deux